-Henrik...
You're wearing your --
-Oh, oh.
-Yeah, sorry.
You're wearing your --
You're wearing your goalie mask,
yeah, on Friday the 13th.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Much better. Much better.
Oh, my gosh.
Happy Friday the 13th.
-Happy 13th.
-Thank you for --
thanks for being here
and coming back to the show.
We always love having you on.
-Thanks for having me.
-The last time you were
on our show
was right before you were --
they were retiring your jersey.
-Yes.
-In the Garden.
And it was unbelievable.
I think I have
a photo of it here.
This is it right here.
Number 30 right there.
-Yeah.
It was just incredible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, to have an opportunity
to bring in your family,
closest friends,
and share that moment
is something
I'll never forget.
-Yeah.
-It was the first time my family
was together in New York.
For different reasons --
My brother's always played
throughout my career,
so he didn't have
the opportunity to come here.
So, obviously, to share
that moment, and, you know...
-Well, the city loves you
so much.
-I appreciate it.
-And I love seeing --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We do.
The greatest.
The last time I saw you,
I don't know
if you remember this.
We sat next to each other
at a Harry Styles concert.
-That's right.
[ Cheering ]
It was boa night at the Garden.
-Here's a selfie that we took.
This is -- you were wearing --
Yeah, you were wearing a boa.
-There it is.
-I want to s--
Well, I want to say,
I think that
you kind of owe me a little bit
because I'll tell you what.
I took a little heat
because I was --
I was dad dancing at Harry --
'Cause I didn't know
how to dance
at a Harry Styles concert.
And you were --
you were there right next to me.
And all these videos
are going around of me
just kind of not knowing
how to dance.
[ Laughter ]
But you were right behind me.
I'm like, "That's Lundqvist.
That's --
That's Henrik Lundqvist
right behind me,
with a boa, going crazy."
You were like, "Yeah!",
screaming.
You love Harry Styles.
-I was just
following your lead that night.
But it was, uh...
[ Laughter ]
You know what?
I have this great opportunity.
I work a lot at the Garden now.
Not playing hockey,
but I may see people.
I go to these amazing concerts.
And Harry --
that was incredible show.
-Wasn't that unbelievable?
-It was.
I brought my kids
for one show,
and I just looked at them.
It felt like we were watching
Elvis or something.
Everybody was just screaming.
I was clapping my hands.
My daughter looked at me,
she's like,
"Dad, we're not clapping.
We're screaming."
-Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Dad, just stop.
Just don't do anything.
Just sit down."
-"Don't embarrass me."
-Exactly.
That's exactly right.
Now you're about to be inducted
into the Hockey Hall of Fame.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Buddy, congratulations.
I'm so --
You know, I'm honored
to know you, but, I mean,
it must mean a lot to you.
As a kid growing up,
you go,
"Well, I just want to --"
You'd be lucky to play
in the league,
let alone be
in the Hall of Fame.
-Listen, it's not something
you really
dream about growing up.
Because what you're dreaming
about is to make the league,
play in the NHL,
and get that opportunity.
You don't really think about
how it's going to end, right?
But here we are,
and I'm just so grateful
and honored to be included.
A lot of those players
that are in the Hall of Fame,
for me, they were idols,
people that I looked up to,
and it's just going to be
a great moment
for me and my family.
And, you know, I thought about
this backstage.
Last time, yeah,
my jersey went up.
-Yeah.
-Now Hall of Fame.
I'm just excited.
Next time I come here,
I don't know if I just landed
on the Moon or something.
-You're gonna land --
Yeah, you're gonna have to
have to go to the --
Every time you come on the show,
it's another giant thing.
-Unbelievable.
-Exactly.
Every single time.
Let's get.
-Thank you. Thank you for that.
-Let's get Henrik to space.
I can call somebody.
We'll make a good...
But I do want to talk about this
next chapter
that you're doing right now,
because this is --
you're coming out --
You have your own fragrance.
-Yes. We just launched
this, Next Chapter.
-You're stylish,
so I trust you on this stuff.
But how much work goes into this
when you're doing it.
-A lot, actually.
This is a niche fragrance,
which means it takes
a lot longer.
Think about it like wine,
for example.
Really nice wine
takes a long time.
This took about 12 to 14 months
to develop.
Regular fragrance of perfume
takes about a week, two weeks.
But when it's a niche perfume
or fragrance, months.
-Really?
And do you do a lot of smelling
and sniff tests?
-Oh, yeah, a lot.
-I think after like
three different smells --
'Cause I do that with candles.
I go, "I'm good.
Everything smells the same."
-Well,
the trick is coffee beans.
Coffee beans
in between to reset.
That's what I learned.
-It's like a palate cleanser.
-Yes, yes.
-A coffee bean.
All right.
So you have two here.
What is this?
Volume one and volume two.
-Yes.
-Of Next Chapter.
Now, which one do you think
is best for me?
-We'll try this.
A little more nighttime.
You're in a suit.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Why not?
-Now, here's the way I do it.
I spray it.
-Oh, you spray...
-And then I go.
-Oh, you do the walk-in,
the walk-in.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh!
-Oh.
-I love this.
-Oh, you love it?
-I feel like a new man.
[ Laughter ]
This is studly.
This is --
I love this.
-That's good.
-I don't know how to describe.
What -- What --
-Can you tell the notes?
-I just played a game with
Kelly.
I really have done all I can.
I --
It smells great, though.
I know that.
I really love -- it's fresh.
It is kind of
a nighttimey type of vibe.
Is there, like, a --
I'm gonna get really nerdy here.
Is there a vetiver
type of a scent?
Did I make that up?
No, no?
-You have that, a little pepper.
-A little pepper in there?
-Ginger.
-Yeah.
-Little ginger.
Can you --
Can you sense that?
-This is wild.
Now let me try the other one.
Can you spray the other one?
I won't dive into this --
Well, why not?
I'll dive in.
Let me dive into this.
This is Volume One
of Next Chapter.
Yeah.
-Oh, there we go.
-Ooh.
-Oh, oh.
-Wow.
-Oh.
-Ooh, that's -- that's electric.
[ Laughter ]
That's a -- that's --
that's more of a daytime.
-Yeah.
-"I got stuff to do. Let's go."
-Now you have
the perfect mix here.
-Gosh, it does.
These both smell great.
Have you ever tried them
both on?
-I try to stick to one.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Shower, and then I go
for the next one.
-I love it, bud.
This is great.
And it is -- it's Next Chapter.
Volume One, Volume Two.
How are you liking
being an analyst, by the way?
You do a great job.
-I love it. You know,
it's a great way for me
to stay connected to the game.
Hockey's been my life since
I was probably 5, 6 years old.
I'm done playing, but now I get
an opportunity to talk about it.
I mean, amazing people,
TNT out in Atlanta,
but also working at MSG Network
here in New York,
covering the Rangers.
And, to me, it's about
the people, you know?
Is it fun to talk about hockey?
Yeah, it's fun,
but the best part is the people
and the teamwork
and just having fun together.
That's what matters
to me the most.
-You're crushing it right now,
buddy, and I'm so happy for you.
Congratulations on
the Hall of Fame.
-Thank you so much.
-You know, Henrik,
whenever you want to come by
here, you're more than welcome.
-I'm so excited about next time.
-Next time, we're going --
we're going to space, baby.
-We're going to space.
-Henrik Lundqvist.
Watch "NHL on TNT"
every Wednesday night.
Kelly Clarkson performs
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.